[Musique]
regardez hier alors que le président
américain assiste à une cérémonie
militaire il chute lourdement trébuchant
sur un sac de sable qui se trouvait sur
Seine au pied du pupitre
puisqu'il parle je vais le mettre dans
une position de sécurité oh là là mais
ne sois pas dur comme ça
[Applaudissements]
tout va bien aucune blessure et de
retour à la Maison Blanche le président
se veut même rassurant
je me suis fait avoir par un sac de
sable
même son grand rival Donald Trump non
rajoute pas
il a des soucis aussi pour trouver ces
mots moi aussi c'est pareil mais
personne ne me demande d'être président
donc oui ça m'inquiète oui quand on
vieillit on tombe mais ça ne veut pas
dire que les gens ne sont pas compétents
je pourrais reconsidérer le fait de
voter pour lui sur tout que ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'il tombe donc
peut-être que je voterai pour quelqu'un
d'autre
[Musique]
enfin bon à quel âge aimeriez-vous
partir à la retraite
on s'est dit on va attaquer avec un
sujet qui va mettre tout le monde à
l'aise ça va être vraiment super alors
je tiens à vous le dire
ils ont répondu majoritairement 71 60
ans exactement
qui a été Président des États-Unis
Martin Luther King
une classe à ciel ouvert une dictée
géante organisée sur les Champs-Élysées
à Paris on en parle ce midi 5000
personnes ont participé à cet événement
une belle occasion de célébrer la langue
française le reste se passe de
commentaires
vous auriez répondu quoi
John Wayne
pas seul là-dedans c'est le nom qui est
classe c'est John c'est John c'est John
prenez une gratte à laquelle vous
accrochez un élastique par
l'intermédiaire d'une épingle à nourrice
l'enfiler le long du bras jusqu'en haut
de l'épaule
qui n'a pas vu Avignon du temps des
papes n'a rien vu un extrait des lettres
de mon moulin d'Alphonse Daudet les
soldats
classiques on valait demander quelques
conseils à l'organisateur de cette
dictée un texte compliqué même pour les
plus entraînés
partout des pluriels partout et non mais
attention bon il y a beaucoup
d'écrivains aujourd'hui donc c'est
bizarre
je sais pas si c'est le cas pour vous
mais il y a beaucoup de personnes qui
parfois pour avoir des coups de fatigue
l'impression de disperser leur énergie
presque des fuites énergétiques quelque
part ce qui nous rend un peu fatigué
alors bien sûr le premier remède c'est
de regarder le mec qui fait du bien mais
pas entendu
donc si vous voulez l'interpeller
l'interroger vous passez par le 32 16
une femme a toujours beaucoup plus de
parole qu'un homme sachez-le que ça soit
en politique ou dans la vie
beaucoup plus sur des femmes dans la
dans le monde professionnel que sur des
hommes ils ont ils sont beaucoup
beaucoup plus respectueux de leurs
paroles c'est incroyable
c'est très difficile de continuer
je vais appliquer la première loi
l'équilibre le sang présent
le milliardaire n'est pas en couple avec
un robot et il compte encore moins
l'épouser une série de publications sur
internet le laisse pour t'en penser en
commentaire on peut lire que sa société
est sur la dernière étape de la
fabrication d'une femme robot qui sera
bientôt commercialisée sauf que ces
images ont été créées de toutes pièces
avec l'intelligence artificielle et bien
voici le petit ami idéal
l'oreiller épaule il remplace l'homme à
la maison et en plus lui ils ne ronfle
pas mal non qui parle de vous quand il a
demandé à me voir j'ai cru que c'était
une blague mais c'était vrai et quand on
s'est rencontré mon équipe était très
émue
en y mettant du flair et de
l'imagination
Caroline une joaillère qui vit à Dubaï
et son compagnon ont déboursé 10000
euros pour une heure de trajet
166 euros la minute de vol
[Musique]
like
c'est la plus belle personne que j'ai
rencontré dans ma vie et qui est
complètement en accord avec les films
qui fait
si vous lui prendre une un truc une
place sur un avion en première classe et
ou demande
en deuxième classe
et il dit d'être assis sur un mauvais
fauteuil ça te permet de tenir de te
tenir de créer de machins et de battre
dans un truc de confort où tu oublies
tout ça quoi pour ce trajet de 445 km le
couple polluent 10 fois plus que s'il
avait pris un vol commercial ce jour-là
il y en avait deux entre Venise et Nice
dans tous les cas c'était pas moi qui
aurait pris ce jet quelqu'un d'autre
donc
[Musique]